young man we're about to meet is one of
our most talented dancers he's also a
distinguished actor writer and director
ladies and gentlemen the star of an
evening without Fred Astaire mr. Gene
Kelly
gene does the active strike settled yet
any late bulletins just one Bob Marilyn
Monroe showed up on the set today and
said where is everybody
she's got the only writer still working
anyway why don't you dance right up to
the envelope Jean huh
thank you Bob now the nominees for the
best scoring of a musical picture they
are elite Stevens for the five pennies
Nelson Riddle and Joseph J Lilly for Lil
Abner Andre Previn and Kent Dhabi for
porgy and bess
Lionel Newman for say one for me and
George Bruns for Sleeping Beauty the
winner is porgy and bess Andre
there are a great great many people to
thank that made the scoring job on 40
possible mr. Gershwin mr. Goldwyn mr.
Preminger the remarkable singers and
that wonderful orchestra and most of all
thank all of you so very very much
congratulations to all those great
musicians really now the nominees for
the best music score of a dramatic or a
comedy picture are McClure's Rocha for
Ben Hur Alfred Newman for the Diary of
Anne Frank Franz Waxman for the nuns
story Ernest gold for on the beach and
Frank the ball for pillow talk and the
winner is Ben Hur McClure Rocha
I would like to thank to all the
musicians who played my music for Ben
Hur and most of them are here in this
Orchestra without their splendid
cooperation this award wouldn't have
been possible